where can you get the best slops on
earth right here in nantucket and
there's one place you come how long
you've been open here
45 years 45 years this is my new gig
from now on you're gonna find me here
hey chef wonderful here where am i you
know i track the world
trying to find the very best of
everything for you then with lobster man
himself eric hogan you know him as a
foodie he is a traditional chef in new
england and what he does
is cook lobster now this is a time
proven method of boiling them alive and
there's a lot of controversy
where can you get the best lobster on
earth right here in nantucket and
there's one place you come it's called
167
raw and people come from all across the
island to get their lobsters here why
the best on earth tonight we're having
what are we having we're having the best
lobster roll on the planet so what
happens is a lobster goes into a trap
one way it gets stuck in the trap and
then we take the lobsters here
we put them in a big pot of water and we
steam them and boil them
there's two ways you can kill a lobster
one is you can you put a knife straight
through its head
yes or the other one is to hypnotize the
lobster before you throw it in which do
you prefer
i prefer the hypnotism i learned it from
a famous chef lucian adrian one of the
top chefs in the world
and he and that's what he preferred so
then you hypnotize the lobster and then
it plunges and
it dies your claim fame really is
lobster does not suffer and it makes a
fantastic
nantucket classic new england dish
which we'll be having tonight i mean
this is doesn't it get any better than
that so why don't we go inside and
claim our order let's go all right
[Music]
uh
[Music]
maria runs the show she's the top queen
boss
and she sells the best lobster on earth
is that true very true how long you've
been open here
45 years 45 years you want to talk about
success
45 years you made money all that time
yes
that's incredible that's a very
successful what do you sell most of
what is our best seller yeah swordfish
swordfish where do you catch them
it's local it was cut 60 miles offshore
really and you know the fishermen that
do that no i personally don't
where do you buy the swordfish from
not from our back door like it used to
be back in the days
so you have to have contracts with this
yeah exactly great
there you have it so we're learning
something here in nantucket maria is the
king
queen bee this is the best place to buy
seafood on nantucket right
yes correct i rest my case
this guy makes his living killing
lobsters is that true
yeah and how do you cook it well
you don't kill them before you cook them
you put them right in the pot you cook
them for
depending on the weight do you think
they're suffering well
sometimes they scream a little bit they
scream do you sleep at night okay
yeah i do you have no problem with it
yeah no problem you want to go see this
pot please yeah let's
go absolutely i've actually got some
more going so let's go here here we go
where's my setup back here check it out
look at this yeah officers that you
ordered we steamed them for 13 minutes
13 minutes so there you have it 13
minutes in this pot steak two pounder is
the most popular right
uh we usually get more one and a half
pound orders actually
these are where they're living right now
oh no that's our we keep the halibut and
the tuna on there okay
but our lobster live back here in this
tank over there
so they're just waiting to enjoy their
time in
the cooker yep wow there you have it
okay can we look inside here whoa
they don't look that happy they're not
happy
they're not having a good time in there
but but they're they're no longer with
us are they
they're not so this is live from the
scene
yeah yeah let's don't cut yourself right
yeah all right
so this is live but this is actually a
live
oyster so we're gonna eat a live voice
once again
yeah there seems to be a lot of uh death
in this place like fish are dying here
right yeah fish are getting whacked you
know but you know it keeps us alive and
we call that sustenance
yeah traditionally we have that we're
gonna leave that right there
oh wow there we go i'm gonna check into
it these are actually pokemons right
right right here from the uh from
nantucket so yeah
so so kevin try this this is live from
the sea
yeah this is it's actually still alive
right still alive still alive
right now here we go ready
just shucked bottoms fresh
itchy is that ever fantastic
oh my goodness you've never heard that
that's live from the seat that's amazing
right now the ceviche we just saw being
made
the cilantro everything we just saw in
the back room all right get a shot of
that okay
ceviche with fresh cilantro okay
who made the ceviche uh our friend edmar
chef edmar on the back
edmar like that fresh halibut yeah i saw
orange lemon lime juice
look at that tomato cilantro okay let's
give it a shot
unbelievable and we make our house-made
tortilla chips in-house okay here we go
what do you think wow
wow
hey how's it going we're just sneaking
me here for a second sure okay chef's
wonderful coming in
look at this okay this okay so we got
the whole crew back here okay
right inside the fruits right and that
is just roasting hot it's 100 degrees in
here what are we cooking there that's a
tuna burger tuna sear it
uh lightly on both sides little guac
pickled bread onions
wow it's it's really really fantastic
tuna burger tuna burger
right this is great no unhealthy
this is my new gig from now on you're
gonna find me here we have nine
two pound lobsters two town claws fresh
from maine
we're gonna rip their tail off yeah okay
take the meat out of the tail
take the meat out of what they call the
knuckle and the claw the knuckle and the
claw
and we're going to make lobster rolls
the most important thing you need
you you need is hot dog rolls but the
hot dog rolls have to be stale
and not so enough lower quality really
yeah that's
a tricky part lower quality stale rolls
at the end of their shelf life got it
and it makes them more absorbent of the
butter
and it makes them steam in the middle
the most controversial part of making a
lobster roll
is the amount of mayonnaise way too many
people have too much mayonnaise
so that's the problem that's the problem
and number two
is they don't take dehydrate the lobster
meat that's critical
and it has to be chilled so you want the
lobster meat dehydrated because you have
wet lobster meat with too much
mayonnaise
it tastes weird yeah so you're going to
take out a claw oh there there
it goes oh oh stop the me
oh the twist that's how it's done and
that's a
woman how do you know that those are
eggs oh
okay okay do we have any guys in this
group we do you can tell the difference
between a male and a female by the
by the legs that are down here and
what's going on is that a male or female
double check make sure our math is right
and that's a male oh so the legs were in
a certain way yeah
so the legs have the extra last little
fluttery legs makes it
male the best the best part of a lobster
yeah is the most work and most people
don't do it
it's right here that little spot right
there
kidding yep it's a lot of work you gotta
really dig in there and together that
meat right there
okay so we have nine two pound lobsters
and we're going to keep working through
the night to get these ready
i think they'll be ready about one
o'clock in the morning this is all just
for
one lobster roll the key thing the
world's best obstacle is the right
amount of mayo
dehydrating lobster meat big mistake a
lot of people make
okay and they don't dehydrate they don't
dehydrate the lobster
and then it's the butt it's the bun you
need a snail
bun stale really low quality stale old
wealthy stale
bunk you would not know this about
lobster rolls unless i traveled the
world i'm on the island of nantucket to
find the best lobster roll on earth
i think we're watching it being made but
who knew about the stale bread story
nobody knows that now you do too wait
it's white flour it's not good for you
and it's stale
but the master says that's what you need
all those lobsters are down to that
that's all
yeah and we're gonna we're gonna
dehydrate it now that's our next step
is to clean and dehydrate so that that
is
18 pounds of lobster is what you get out
of that
okay that's your gold so what exactly is
going on here
we're taking all the water out of the
lobster we want no water left on the
lobster kathy is that right
and that's exactly what i would do then
the flavor comes out
of the lobster lobster it is
incredible we need some of your stuff oh
look at that
a big piece fell out oh no
[Music]
we're buttering buns inside outside
grilled inside with melted
butter it's just easier to do when it's
melted and you get an
even distribution and you know the way i
like my lobster rolls
a blt lobster roll it'll make you throw
rocks at your granny it's that good
what are we talking about here we have
some fresh flat leaf parsley
which has a lot of flavor more than the
curly parsley two types of potato chips
salt and vinegar and plain going in the
roll
no it's your side to the lobster you
need the crumbs and look at this finely
minced
about one large shallot finely finely
minced
and then we're going to do a little bit
of lemon i believe inside
as well we've watched the whole process
tonight of making lobster rolls
and kathy eric we've been everywhere to
get the
essence of the roll itself we've
experienced what happens with lobsters
how they're cooked
the amount of work to create this
bringing them
dehydrating them in the freezer the
elixir
all this stuff the butter the you saw
kathy buttering the rolls just so right
and eric talking about all this stuff
about the stale rolls and all this stuff
this is the essence of the new england
lobster
bowl you can go anywhere else on earth
and you'll get a discount roll this is
the
elsa primo mega roll okay fresh
lemon juice
the juice the juice
oh stop the madness okay
yikes so when do you know when enough is
enough eric
that's it that's it just a sprinkling a
tease
a new walls and now this is the moment
where really the roll is created
it's malt and salt from davis
[Music]
look at that we have the right amount of
mayonnaise we've got lobsters that want
us to give their lives up for this roll
we have these stale really crappy
lobster roll
with white no it's no bread
[Music]
classic nantucket lobster roll lumber
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe